lors d'un saut au 2t daguerre qui sait
pas quand est ce qu'on va voir ça
on se pose les repose la question assez
souvent au québec y at il suffisamment
de diversité à la télé au cinéma ou
encore au théâtre pascal il ya plusieurs
bons choix bon ça il y en a plusieurs
qui estime que le québec et peut-être
même en retard sur l'ensemble de
l'amérique du nord pour ce qui est de la
diversité à l'écran mais suffit d'ouvrir
le téléviseur de regarder la télévision
américaine où plus près de chez nous à
les productions du canada anglais ici
c'est difficile de mettre le doigt
exactement sur le problème parce
qu'aucune statistique qui existent sur
la diversité toutefois plusieurs acteurs
qui n'hésite pas à le dire il ya un
problème comment équilibrer rééquilibrer
tout ça plusieurs pistes de solution
voici ce que je te prie préval
interpréter une scène d'une pièce
québécoise lors des auditions de la
diversité n'était pas un choix innocent
pour jean jacques simon l'événement une
première a rassemblé des dizaines de
professionnels du petit et du grand
écran venus voir de nouveaux visages et
entendre de nouveaux accents je veux
c'est une belle occasion de présenter
des 5 on aurait cependant clichés du
black en quelque sorte donc pas le gars
de gang de rue pas le chauffeur de taxi
et l'attribution d'un rôle principal de
la version anglophone de 19,2 à un duel
rose a semé une graine d'espoir
l'espoir de voir plus souvent des
visages différents dans des rôles non
typé mais est ce que le québec
francophone est prêt pas toujours selon
cette agence qui représente plusieurs
artistes de la diversité ses clients qui
tente de décrocher des rôles destinés à
tous se rendent trop rarement jusqu'à
l'étape des auditions on sait faire mais
c'est parce que ça représente pas
ça représente pas le milieu rural des
gens qui écoutent la télé
il ya peut-être un malaise de voir une
personne de couleur
mais je passerai pas on est rendu au 21e
siècle un obstacle de plus pour un
métier beaucoup sont appelés et trop peu
sont élus j'en veux plus de vingt ans
tout en en sait quelque chose après
avoir roulé sa bosse pendant 20 ans
c'est finalement le rôle de taille dans
19 2 qui l'a fait connaître du grand
public
et bien qu'ils goûtent aux effets de la
notoriété il doit encore passer son
temps entre montréal et toronto et los
angeles pour travailler c'est pas juste
en écriture cédant casting moi je trouve
que la façon d'y affecter le plus vite
c'est d'être créatif d'encasté comme on
dit quand le guen castet certaines
séries ont réservé davantage de place à
des rôles écrits pour des acteurs issus
des minorités culturelles en train de
vie par exemple les origines des
personnages sont multiples qui ose y
l'amérique est essentiellement un rêve
qui ne s'est pas encore réalisé martin
luther king mais pour son auteur il ya
certaines limites le vrai débat c'est au
monde que qui le fait le chi qui
travaillent tous les jours a écrit des
personnages c'est le bassin le bassin de
d'acteurs et d'actrices de communautés
culturelles qui vient d'ailleurs ça je
pense que on un problème de formation
d'acteurs et d'actrices à l'école
nationale de théâtre
à peine une poignée de candidats issus
des communautés culturelles sur
plusieurs centaines se présentent aux
auditions c'est pourquoi l'équipe de
denise guilbault a organisé un stage
l'été dernier pour rencontrer ces jeunes
de la diversité pour les former et mieux
les orienter la société est
multiculturelle
si c'est parce qu'on retrouve sur les
saintes s'est pas représentatifs de
notre société
honnêtement on est dans trop parce que
qu'ils feraient en train au théâtre qui
quelle personne jours on va jouer entre
nous dans une minorité mais les choses
car aucun bon sens 25 % des stagiaires
rencontré passeront les auditions de
l'école cet ami et auront peut-être la
chance de devenir la prochaine vedette
d'une télésérie d'un film ou d'une pièce
de théâtre je m'appuie vidange pascal
russell julien laz au canada son accord